so one story that we don't know about
care that you just remember that you
just a small moment
oh god that it's a 34 years in so many
moments
oh oh oh you've caught me off balance
moment that was just you and her a
million of them I know just lying in our
bed Bailey enough watching old movies a
million of them I can't I'll tell you a
moment
my son was dying and he was triaged into
Columbia Presbyterian in New York I was
in Alaska my son was eight weeks old and
I was film and I didn't know what to do
and I called Kerry and it was about 1:00
in the afternoon and Kerry was there by
midnight with a pillow and a blanket and
she stayed with me until my son was okay
three days later there's a moment for
well and she just went come on let's go
shopping in the gift shop no I don't
want to put the baby down Beth come on
you know but uh that's a set oh I went
to the sad no that's good good friend
she could you always hear these funny
stories that that's it I will tell you
this that that weekend that we met the
the hysteria the myriad of hot springs
we drove home together I'd taken a limo
down there we drove home together and we
stopped at a place and got our hair
crimped in the same hairstyle they were
like these crimping islands that we had
like really weird hair that was fun
how old were you when I met Carrie twins
[Music]
all right I love this this is great okay
I love you melody